do you not want to work with certain
races of people well great news LinkedIn
will now allow users to filter job
applicants by their race LinkedIn users
can now search for applicants of a
preferred race sex gender identity and
sexual orientation
the new feature is part of linkedin's
diversity in recruiting tools meaning
that the intention of the tool is not as
some might worry to discriminate against
black people or Hispanic people or trans
identifying people or LGB identifying
people or any other supposedly
marginalized group on the contrary the
tool is designed to designate in favor
of all those groups If an employer ever
discriminated against those groups he
would be hauled into court he would
likely lose his business
if on the other hand he used the tool as
it is intended and discriminated on
behalf of those groups against all the
other groups white people straight
people and so on he would be applauded
by our culture and political class
which is why I can't muster very much
outrage at LinkedIn for this move
yes this kind of discrimination is ugly
and unjust
but that is not linkedin's fault
LinkedIn is just following the unjust
laws that the libs have enshrined
changing some feature on the least
important social media network is not
going to do much of anything
if you don't like this Injustice the
only solution that will actually fix the
problem is to change the law I'm Michael
Knowles this the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show uh in just a
moment we will have a really important
Story coming out of a Washington Middle
School in which teachers and students
are licking opposite sides of a pane of
glass and slurping up whipped cream as
part of
some kind of lesson I don't I think the
real lesson is that kovid's over I guess
but we we will get to that in just one
second as the sexualization of young
school children continues first though
back on this racial politics stuff
did you know that Netflix is making a
docudrama about Cleopatra
that doesn't seem particularly unusual
Cleopatra is a very important historical
figure
what's strange about the docudrama is
that they've decided to cast a black
woman as Cleopatra
the docudrama is called African queens
Queen Cleopatra and so I I can
understand you you're African and some
people who don't know about the history
of Africa the difference between North
Africa and sub-Saharan Africa you might
think well African that must mean that
she's African but Cleopatra very much
was not African she was Macedonian Greek
this is not particularly controversial
and they cast a black actress to play
her
this is not complicated
this is just about antipathy toward
white people a while ago there was a
conservative who posted on Twitter and
said that daily wire's new movie Project
was going to be a biography a biopic of
Malcolm X and it was going to star me
and everyone laughed because that would
be ridiculous I don't think that I'm
going to be playing Malcolm X I don't
think that uh Ryan Gosling is going to
be playing Martin Luther King Jr anytime
soon if this happened Not only would
people laugh at it but of course there'd
be a national uproar film studios would
shut down people would burn Effigies and
set the country on fire
and in the other direction
it doesn't matter this isn't hypocrisy
this is just antipathy toward white
people in our culture you see this
enshrined in the law white people are
basically the only group that Asians
fall into it a little bit too of of
people against whom you can discriminate
on the basis of race that's true in
college admissions that's true in
employment and it's true in our popular
culture white people are the only race
that you are encouraged to insult and
make fun of and deride it's not only
acceptable but actually encouraged in
our culture and that's just the way it
is
and that's what this is about this is
why Cleopatra can be played by a black
woman but I will not be able to play
Malcolm X in the new biopic
this is not to say that you can never
have any race bending in movies a great
example of I I felt perfectly suitable
race spending was the Denzel Washington
Macbeth movie which is one of maybe the
greatest performance of Macbeth I've
ever seen and the reason this was I felt
totally fine is because we're not
talking about a history here we're not
talking about a biopic or a docudrama
we're talking about a very famous play
we're talking about Shakespeare which
who who is the most important playwright
in the English language and one of the
aspects of Shakespeare that that has
made him so important is that he writes
about The Human Experience
and so while there are different races
of people in his plays that's secondary
to what he's saying about human nature
the other reason it didn't really matter
all that much is Denzel is just such an
incredible actor that
I just want to see the guy play Macbeth
he's just a very very good actor and it
wasn't distracting and it in no way did
this casting decision detract from the
play
here we're talking about and historic
not only an historical figure but a
docudrama so if you know you're just
completely rewriting history which is
what the libs do all the time we're
going to need to tell each other about
Real History okay we're gonna need to
talk about it when you want to talk you
got to check out pure talk right now go
to puretalk.com use promo code Knowles
tax season is here you want to make your
accountant happy I got one super easy
way to do it switch to pure talk instead
of paying a fortune to Verizon ATT or
T-Mobile cut your bill in half with pure
talk Pure Talk offers unlimited talk
text and plenty of data starting at just
30 bucks a month and saving the average
family over 900 a year a lot of people
think the bigger the provider the better
the service let me fill you in on a
little secret Pure Talk uses the same
network not saying a comparable Network
I'm saying the exact same network for
less there's no contract no hidden fees
no hassle switch over to Pure Talk in as
little as 10 minutes while keeping your
phone and your phone number they're
us-based customer service team
worth the switch just for the us-based
customer service team make that switch
really really easy pure talks so sure
you're going to love the service they're
backing it up with a 100 money back
guarantee your first month is guaranteed
risk free go to puretalk.com enter promo
code knows to save 50 off your first
month puretalk.com promo code nulls Pure
Talk is simply smarter Wireless
speaking of more racial politics
leftist Congress lady pramila jayapal
I'm probably mispronouncing that but
there it goes
a congresswoman jayapal is arguing for
U.S amnesty for millions of illegal
aliens Millions really probably tens of
millions of illegal aliens and what's
her argument why do we need to give a
bunch of foreign Nationals who are in
our country illegally why do we need to
give them amnesty
well she says
America needs immigrants
in order to survive
quote immigrants pick the food we eat
clean our homes she goes on to list a
number of other service industry jobs
and you hear this line all the time
these are the two most shallow left-wing
arguments on immigration they'll say
well without immigration you couldn't
get tacos
could you imagine a world without
Chinese food that's why we need to open
up our borders and flood our country
with three million foreigners every year
well we can welcome some people in with
just completely Opening Our borders I
think we've got enough Taco stands I I
like tacos as much as the next guy we're
good I think we've saturated the Taco
Market we don't need to ignore our laws
disrupt our social order upend our
self-governing Republic in order to get
another Taco I think we're good on that
but then the the other argument they
make is they say well there are jobs
that Americans won't do if we don't let
desperate foreigners in who are who's
going to scrub our toilets
which is offensive to everybody
because it insinuates that Americans
won't clean Americans are are pretty
cleanly people
if you've ever traveled to Europe for
instance you'll notice that Americans
are almost neurotically hygienic
compared to Europeans certainly compared
to really everybody in the world
I haven't traveled extensively through
any other places so my frame of
reference is Europe but I've heard that
China is not the most sanitary place I
did go to India once not all that clean
I've never been to Africa but I've heard
it's not
not the most enjoyable experience when
it comes to basic sanitation so no I
think America
in our own bathrooms if we wanted to
that's not an argument for for breaking
the law
need them to to pick our food I think
Americans can pick food they can do that
but but then it's offensive in the other
way too because immigrants believe it or
not can can do things other than clean
our toilets
immigrants even from those poor
countries in Latin America or the Middle
East or Africa or anywhere else
believe it or not they're human
they can do other jobs they don't just
need to pick grapes and scrub our
bathrooms they can do other things it's
so
patronizing condescending dehumanizing
it's it's a it's a perfect
Democrat political argument
because
it is deeply offensive to everybody and
and not terribly persuasive speaking of
out of touch Elites though
the real breaking news yesterday
that that is causing garments to be rent
in in newsrooms all around the country
it's called causing gnashing of teeth
everywhere in the
liberal establishment
they all lost their blue checks
yesterday on Twitter Elon Musk had
threatened to take away their blue
checks
he said he was going to take them away
on 420 it was kind of it was just a 420
joke
and then he did it he followed through
I'm one of those blue checks I lost my
blue check yesterday
and
I'm happy about it I think it's really
funny the
outcry of grief from the libs
to me is worth the eight dollars a month
that I will have to pay if I want to get
my blue check mark back
now people are saying
that this is a terrible move by Elon
because the point of the blue check mark
was to verify people and to protect
against
uh stolen identities and imitation of
public figures okay and now Elon by
turning it into something that you can
just pay for
taking it away from notable public
figures he is just destroying Twitter
Elon Musk did not destroy the meaning of
the blue check mark
the libs at Twitter in the pre-ylon days
they destroyed the meaning of the blue
check mark
the check mark was called a verification
but the libs at Twitter especially
around 2016 began to treat the blue
check mark as a sign of prestige
as a sign of the approval of the liberal
establishment
so if someone got a little bit too edgy
they would just take away the check mark
I remember this most clearly with
Richard Spencer who is a white
identitarian type and Richard Spencer
who had a real moment as being the the
most odious figure in American life and
the libs ran all sorts of
specials about him even though he wasn't
particularly influential and he was
pretty forthright about his views he
said I'm a white identitarian I'm a
white identity activist and he had a
check mark because he
had some prominence for some time
largely because CNN and the libs made
such a big deal about him
and then one day they took away his
check mark they didn't kick him off
Twitter
they didn't block his posts they just
removed his check mark and I thought
what
did he stop being Richard Spencer why
did he he's no longer verified as you
don't know did someone hack his account
what do you no they changed the meaning
of the check and then Elon comes in
and
mischievous Elon over there
takes away their Prestige I just I love
it I think it's terrific
I I wasn't planning on paying the eight
dollars for it because I thought
okay well I had my got my blue check a
while ago it was cool now lose my blue
check it's fine I haven't really looked
into the extra features that you get if
you do pay the eight bucks they're
probably worth it eight dollars a month
for a major social media platform
especially if you work in media it's not
not a big deal but I've decided I think
I am going to pay the eight dollars
and I'm gonna pay the eight dollars for
two reasons one because the libs have
turned the blue check now into a
referendum on whether or not you support
what Elon Musk is doing at Twitter
and I do support what he's doing at
Twitter I think it's really important
and Noble of him to do so I think that's
worth eight dollars Elon Musk doesn't
need my eight dollars but Twitter
probably does because it's very hard for
Twitter to be profitable and so if I can
show my support of him standing up for
traditional standards of speech in
America I'm more than happy to do it but
then the other reason the more pressing
reason as to why I think I'm going to
pay my eight bucks get my blue check
mark back
because of what Elon said about aliens
in the great debate here at the daily
wire between me and Mr Walsh over the
non-existence of aliens
Elon who who would know more about
aliens than anybody else on Earth
he's on team Knowles is that worth eight
bucks a month yeah that's worth like 80
bucks a month okay so I will I I'll try
to get around to it today but I will get
my blue check mark back
and
that'll make me feel really really great
not about being verified or prominent
but about supporting a guy who's doing
the right thing for free speech in
America and who also realizes that
aliens are totally fake speaking of big
changes to online journalism
BuzzFeed news is shutting down
you're you're hearing that and you're
probably thinking who cares I haven't
thought about BuzzFeed news in years I
know neither have I
but people used to talk about BuzzFeed
news
10 years ago eight nine ten years ago
BuzzFeed news was the future of the news
you might remember that BuzzFeed news or
a fictional version of BuzzFeed news was
a major plot point on House of Cards
back when House of Cards was one of the
biggest shows in the country this was
going to be the future of Journalism I
remember when the daily wire started out
we would regularly talk about what
success looked like
what if we could become as big as this
right-wing blog or this online journal
or oh could you imagine the gold
standard would be if we could be
BuzzFeed news wow could you imagine
now BuzzFeed news is gone
now daily wire has blown way past that
thanks to all of you who listen and
subscribed
we don't give out blue check marks when
you subscribe but we appreciate your
membership uh in any case but
but it's much bigger than that now and
BuzzFeed news is gone
shows you that things can change real
fast in politics we were talking about
this yesterday on the show
hours of sitting with a friend of mine
my friend says did you ever think
that that tranzing the kids would be the
issue did you ever think that whether or
not you can shop a guys
genitals off and pretend that he's a
lady that that would be the big issue
we're all talking about in 2023
back in 2008 Clinton and Obama were both
running on marriage being the sacred
Union between a man and a woman they
were mocking the notion of same-sex
marriage now we're at the point where we
say should we trans the five-year-old
should we wait till they turn six or
seven
and I said to my friend
things change very fast
very very fast and this is depressing
because of the way that things have
degraded so quickly in the United States
but this should offer a little glimmer
of hope to conservatives here there's a
line from Cardinal Manning who says
there is a day to come that will
challenge The Confident judgments of men
there's so many people
who say the conservatives are finished
Progressive liberal Society has won
we've reached the end of History 99
chance that Donald Trump doesn't win in
2016. you hear you hear this stuff all
the time
and then what happens
then things can change very very quickly
speaking of great changes
Governor Ron DeSantis down there in
Florida has expanded the don't say gay
so-called Bill the conservatives were
defending it calling it The wait till
eight bill it was a bill that said that
in elementary schools teachers can't
trans the kids until the fourth grade
they can't start preaching
transgenderism in the classroom from
kindergarten through third grade
it seems reasonable enough
but it seemed kind of weak didn't it I'm
not knocking DeSantis he did what he
felt he had the political Capital to do
at the moment but I thought this is it
this is where the this is the reason I
gave my CPAC speech I said the fight
over transgenderism now is
third right versus fourth grade give me
a break give me a transgenderism is just
false it shouldn't be taught anywhere it
shouldn't be tolerated as a matter of
public life it's a false anthropology
and I strongly encourage conservative
politicians to take a much tougher
stance on it to not not feel like we had
to be backed in this corner but to go on
the offense because the American people
are on our side according to Pew
research 60 of Americans believe that
gender is determined by biological sex
and though that number should be higher
the number is up from 2021 just a couple
of years ago the number was 56 percent
uh back in 2017 the number is 54 so the
clear majority of Americans are on our
site on transgenderism period not just
for the kids but the whole thing and
that number is increasing so Now's the
Time to move and that's what Rhonda
Santos is doing uh his administration
has expanded the so-called don't say gay
Bill and said okay we're not going to
teach transgenderism anywhere K through
12. great stuff Governor DeSantis love
to see that and he's come out strong he
was just being interviewed by Benny
Johnson and he was asked about
transgenderism broadly here's here's the
governor's line
some of this is yes it's taking away
opportunities and Athletics and some
other stuff and that's really really
important but I think there's also just
the issue of are we going to be a
society based on truth are we going to
be a society based on deceit and if you
take a man and they dress up as a woman
and you tell me I have to accept that
they're a woman then you're asking me to
be complicit in a lie and I just refuse
to do that so we've got to tell the
truth uh I think you know the truth will
set you free and let's just be honest
about what's going on here
love this great stuff I I wish if I had
a moving camera I would give up and give
Governor DeSantis a standing ovation for
saying this this is the line every
Republican running for president every
Republican running for office should
adopt this transgenderism is not about
whether to pump cross-sex hormones into
seven-year-olds versus eight-year-olds
transgenderism is either entirely true
or entirely false there were some
political issues where you can have a
nice conciliatory Middle Ground like on
taxes or immigration well I want to take
in two million neurons I want to take in
no immigrants okay let's take in 500 000
okay I want tax rates to be 30 I want
them to be 25 okay we'll meet at 27.
certain issues you can't meet in the
middle because they're mutually
exclusive
they're mutually contradictory options
if transgenderism is true at all for
anybody in society at any age
and then we let those men go into the
women's bathroom then that means women's
bathrooms cease to exist the very
concept of a bathroom only for women
ceases to exist and I use the bathrooms
because they're so evocative but it's
true of all the rights and privileges of
women in society as women
the moment you entertain transgenderism
at all for even one single person
you obliterate the category of women
and the rights that they have
traditionally had for all of human
history certainly for the history of our
civilization so you can't try to find a
middle ground here you'll split the baby
it'll be no good for anybody
you've got to come out and say are we
going to be a society based on truth or
a society based on cynicism the cynicism
of Pontius Pilate who says what is truth
a society that ignores the truth that
Society is not going to do very well the
society based on truth will
so great stuff great stuff here from
Governor DeSantis hope to see more of it
from all the other Republicans
now
when when we talk about these basic
things very often it's not on TV it's
not even on social media it's often with
our friends and our family and our
communities just hanging out having a
nice time during the summer taking that
Grill pill okay and when you want to
make sure that you have propane to grow
for your friends you got to check out
cinch right now go to cinch.com use
promo code Knowles the weather is
warming up over here in Nashville do you
know what that means it's grilling
season time to take that Grill pill baby
and I could not be more excited about
backyard Gatherings this summer but the
last thing you're going to want to do
when you've got all your friends coming
over for a barbecue is drive around
worrying about where to refill the
propane tank that is where cinch comes
in clutch cinch is a propane grill tank
delivery service they deliver propane
tanks right to your door cinch delivers
on your schedule and requires no
long-term commitment or subscription
plus delivery is completely contactless
you don't have to wait around at home
track the order on the Cinch app from
anywhere whether you're grilling for the
game camping with your family or
lighting up your patio heaters on a cold
night cinches propane delivery service
ensures you have the fuel you need to
make the most of every moment go online
to cinch.com download their app to order
new customers can get their first tank
exchange for just ten dollars with promo
code Knolls go to cinch.com or download
the Cinch app use promo code Knolls to
get your first tank exchange for just 10
bucks
cynch.com promo code Knowles this is a
limited time offer you must live within
a cinched service area to redeem it
cinch.com offer for details my favorite
comment yesterday is from Michael
popescu who says my co-workers are
wondering why I'm dying laughing after
that trans slenderism line thanks
Michael as that occurred to me yesterday
while we were discussing the public
health scourge of fat phobia according
to that Viral tick tocker
and I said we had to move from
transgenderism to discussing trans
slenderism I don't think it's an
original phrase I'm sure I saw that on a
meme somewhere but whoever said it
brilliant stuff and I'm more than happy
to popularize this new very important
term okay speaking of really
weird
obviously sexual stuff
there's a Washington Middle School I
have to give a shout out to Ali London
for for finding this a middle school in
Washington that was holding a
competition and it was a competition not
only between
students
and not only between staff members but
between students and staff members
sometimes competing against each other
and the competition was you would squirt
a little bit of whipped cream on a pane
of Glass on either side of a pane of
glass and you'd have one person on one
side and one person on the other and
then
they would lick the cream exactly
opposite one another
yeah
what
[Applause]
[Music]
the heck
all right that's actually that's enough
I've seen I've I've never I hadn't
hadn't seen the video I just saw the
report on it and
had our editors pull the clip but that's
enough I think I get it how do you watch
that video how do you even hear about
this story and conclude that this isn't
a weird sex thing
for whoever thought it up
I I don't see how one I guess the silver
lining the storm cloud is glad to see
that covet is over in the schools glad
to see that now not only are we allowed
to meet with one another but we're
allowed to just lick panes of glass and
then swap out the students and the
teachers and then they lick all the same
panes of glass and I'm glad that that's
over but two
foreign
in what world is this acceptable I'll
tell you the world that this is
acceptable and this is acceptable at a
weird party in college that's put on
probably in some frat house basement
where everyone is just kind of giggling
and they're all being a little bit
naughty and tihi are you gonna lick the
whipped cream off the glass or whatever
okay that's where I would expect to see
a game like this
just a a more
licentious version of spin the bottle or
something okay
I that kind of a game makes sense to me
in that kind of environment I'm not
saying I'm encouraging it or anything
like that but I get it there
that kind of a game very much does not
make sense in a middle school
this is one of the more nuanced
conservative points on the whole drag
queen story hour discussion and debate
it's a point that Jonathan pegeot has
alluded to as well if you tell me that
we have a society in which in some dark
alley way in the bad part of town with
the red lights there's a cabaret that
puts on weird drag shows for guys who
show their ID and pay some money to get
in and they're kind of embarrassed by it
but whatever it's some weird Quirk that
they have
I get that I'm not recommending that I'm
not saying that's a great thing that
Society should embrace but okay I get
that
but the moment that you take that Fringe
bizarre
shameful activity and you put that in
the very center of society you take it
away from that side street you put it in
the Public Square right in the middle
you put it on TV you put it in the
elementary school classroom then things
have gotten really strange
and and the way that uh Jonathan pegeot
alludes to this is he says if you look
at Medieval manuscripts or if you look
at Medieval and Gothic Cathedrals you'll
see gargoyles and and all sorts of
eccentric things on the fringes on the
outside in the corners of the cathedral
end of the manuscript
elves with horns and weird sort of
genitals doing all sorts of silly
mischievous things
you'll see that on the on the fringes
well there are fringes to society
but when you put the things that are
supposed to be on the fringes at the
center of society then you invert your
standards then Society gets to be really
really weird
I would recommend
that the school investigate whoever came
up with this idea because while it might
seem like weird
basically innocent kind of fun to some
people whoever proposed and permitted
this kind of a game to go on is
definitely a creep there's just no way
about it okay
now getting back to 2024 and the
DeSantis of all of it all for a second
I just would like to establish at the
outset I've said from the beginning I do
not
as a rule make endorsements in primary
campaigns I don't think that's my job
and in especially in 2024
I think we're in Uncharted Territory in
terms of a defeated Republican pretty
well
a reportedly defeated Republican
president who is then running for
reelection and you got a strong
Republican governor coming there but
you've got a big split in the GOP
between the old kind of liberal way of
doing things the squishy way of doing
things and this new Insurgent muscular
assertive more nationally focused more
populist more virtue-minded rather than
libertarian-minded kind of conservatism
and so
I I think we ought to let the thing play
out I love Donald Trump he's the best
president of my lifetime I just think
he's terrific and I think he offered a
real alternative to a lot of the squishy
Republican policies
of the past because of the Trump
movement you saw Governors like Ron
DeSantis come up and Ronda Santos has
done terrific job in Florida so Ronda
Santos now is making the argument I'm
younger I'm I'm I get what's going on
here I don't have the baggage that Trump
does so he's making his play and they're
they're both making the play for the
same kind of campaign then there are a
lot of other people running for
president as well so I'm just putting
this out at the front I know there are a
lot of pundits who say I'm only for
DeSantis I'm totally on the DeSantis
train or they'll say DeSantis is a total
establishment squish hack neocon or
whatever things are saying because
they're on the Trump train
and here I am here I am the the lone
Republican saying this is a primary
let's recognize that Trump's the best
president in our lifetimes let's
recognize that DeSantis has done a great
job as Governor let's recognize these
are big boys they got thick skin they
know how to make it through an election
they can run for an office we'll let the
process play out
so one of the people who's now coming
out in favor of DeSantis as the
politicians are going to do now you're
going to increasingly see more and more
endorsements among the electeds is Chip
Roy who is great member of Congress uh
former Chief of Staff to Ted Cruz I'm
pretty sure he was Ted's Chief of Staff
now a member of Congress in his own
right and he says
I love Trump but I'm endorsing DeSantis
like I was a strong supporter of Senator
Ted Cruz in 2016 in the primary yeah got
behind president Trump uh once we uh
chose him as the nominee on May 3rd of
that year I remember it well this time
I'm supporting Ron DeSantis I'll support
the Republican nominee no matter what
I'm a strong supporter of the America
First agenda but look I I put out in my
statement I think it's time to have
someone who's not a baby boomer somebody
who can serve for two terms that we know
we can get behind to root out all the
corruption in this town and beat the
swamp that President Trump so ably
started when he came in in 2016. and
look Governor DeSantis has an enormously
successful record and he just won
re-election by a million and a half
votes he won 62 percent of Hispanic
voters 50 50 percent of single females
they have massive job growth great
economy he's taking on the education
establishment he's taken on the
corporate establishment with Disney and
so I just think it's time we have
someone that we can take a new
generation into town and we can kind of
to build on what president Trump started
and Governor DeSantis is a great guy to
get behind to do that
okay very well articulated endorsement
what's interesting to me is not that he
picked DeSantis over Trump or anything
like that what's most interesting to me
is how temperate this endorsement was
how polite this endorsement was
and I think you're going to see a lot of
these kinds of endorsements especially
from the serious people which is
I love Trump but I think DeSantis is
better for the moment or contrary to
that I love DeSantis he's a good
Governor but I think Trump is better for
the moment
that and there are other candidates as
well our friend Larry Elder just
announced that he's going to run for
president obviously we've had Vivek on
the show before we've had Nikki Haley on
the show before there are other people
who are who are running and they
very possibly will have moments in the
race and who knows they could maybe take
the whole thing
all the Republicans now that I talk to
they're a little bit upset because they
say ah I just wish DeSantis would wait
his turn
ah now it's going to be a mean primary
or contrary to say I just oh I wish
Trump would get out of the way oh I'm
just give it to DeSantis
when you've got endorsements that say I
love this guy but I'm giving this other
one the slight Edge
that's a good problem to have it's a
good problem to have that we have strong
GOP candidates who are moving the party
in the right direction on policy can we
be happy with that conservatives we
always want to be so doer you know we
always want to say oh the world is
ending it's all it's all over we've lost
everything our problem right now in 2024
is that we've got two candidates who are
too good who we like too much
and more than that actually because as
you know we're I think I'm going to try
to interview all of the all of the
Republican candidates we've got more
than that DeSantis and Trump are the two
Far and Away at the top of the polls
right now but we've got lots of
candidates who are great I'm looking
down at my iPad with the member chat
people love the bake people love people
are saying oh Larry Elder just announced
there's a lot of great candidates
take the win guys let the process play
out see who's the toughest one see who's
the best one and we go on and we try to
undo the rigging of Elections by the
Democrats and we try to own the libs
sounds sounds like a plan to me let me
ask you a question
when was the last time you prayed maybe
a better question to ask is when was the
last time you thought about the meaning
of prayer many of us see prayer as a way
of petitioning God for something
but as with all things concerning God
there is more to it than that that is
the way Ben describes it in the latest
episode of Exodus the Fantastic series
from Jordan Peterson
the idea of of prayer that you're
talking about is obviously a lot more
meaningful because it's really not about
changing God's mind it's about changing
who you are and thus God naturally
responds to you differently because
you're not the person that you were
before you prayed and the the verb to to
pray in Hebrew is actually in the
reflexive tense right right which is
supposed to the idea is that it's
supposed to be something that acts on
you the prayer is supposed to act on you
it's not supposed to be something where
you're attempting to pry an answer out
of God
Ben and Jordan are joined by a group of
esteemed Scholars theologians and
artists for an in-depth discussion on
one of the wonderful most important
books ever written in the actual full
most important book ever written in the
Bible
it is every bit as Illuminating as you
would hope new episodes are coming
online every week exclusively for daily
wire Plus members joining at
dailywire.com subscribe to watch Exodus
and now finally finally we've arrived at
my favorite time of the week when I get
to hear from you in the mailbag the
mailbag is sponsored by Pure Talk go to
puretalk.com select to plan enter code
Knowles kwles get 50 off your first
month take it away
hello Mr Knowles it has slap my base
once again and I'm coming to you with a
situational question let's call it am I
the Democrat so I have been asked to
travel for work about three states away
from where I live and it happens to fall
on the same weekend as my cousin's
wedding now I had been asked to travel
for work months prior to being invited
to the wedding and I've already declined
going to my cousin's wedding
because I had been asked to work and
naturally my family is extremely upset
they are already not talking to me they
are holding it against me
but at the same time too I'm on the idea
that it's first come first serve so my
question to you is am I the Democrat for
accepting to take a business trip to
work prior to going to a family event or
should I have canceled the business trip
explain to my work that this is a family
event that I need to attend
your input would be very greatly
appreciated thanks
no you're right your family is wrong the
only caveat is
are you that close with your cousin are
you in the wedding party are you the
best man I mean maybe in that case
there's an argument to say all right
I've got to ditch this work trip to go
to the wedding but
if
your cousin is your cousin and so your
family you love your family but
you know you're not roommates or
anything like that and no you you've got
to work that's okay it's it's
the families that I have seen work best
are the families who
love each other unconditionally love
spending time together
but don't
feel the need to spend all the time
together that don't constantly put these
kind of guilt trips on people that's
that's not not good you're a man you've
got to work it's nice to go to your
cousin's wedding but
you've agreed to take on this
responsibility for your job and that's
what you're supposed to do are you kid
are you the demo give me a break
no I don't think so Buster that's good
you can you know if it's your brother's
wedding I don't know if you but we need
to use Prudence here okay we need to
recognize there are gradations of
importance next question hello Michael
you have had quite an impact on my 20
year old son and for he and I to bond we
listen to your show together and we
watch it as well sometimes
I appreciate your conservative approach
and the daily wire influence in general
and I enjoy listening and watching with
my son
I am a dental hygienist
and I was just curious how often you see
your dental hygienist if you go every
six months because you have an
impressive set of teeth I can see that
good Oral Care must be important to you
um so how often do you see your dental
hygienist
never
I never go to the dentist
I don't have a dentist in Tennessee
I I'm honored I I feared you were going
to say Michael I'm a dental hygienist
and you need to go in for emergency
reconstructive surgery especially
because I drink coffee
and dark liquor
and red wine
I smoke cigars
I you with but you know what I do I use
an electric toothbrush
right so they get nice and pearly white
I don't know maybe it's good jeans I
don't know what it is but thank you and
you're making now you're making me think
I need to go to the dentist it's like
when you do go to the dentist and then
the dentist or the dental hygienist says
hey how often are you flossing when was
the last time you flossed and a lot of
people say I don't know the last time
you did it probably was the last time
I've I don't know every so often and
even when you do floss you know say oh
you're not doing it right and however
you do it you end up you're not doing it
right so now I haven't gone but you've
guilted me into thinking
I probably should maybe you'll be my
dental hygienist I don't know where
you're based but but I can tell you are
very based so maybe I'll have to look
into that next question
hey Michael so my wife and I have been
together for about five years we have a
14 month old daughter and my wife is
eight months pregnant uh so my question
is my mom is a very difficult person
she's not respecting her rules my
parents actually had to leave their
church because my mom got in a huge
fight with their Pastor I've had about
half a dozen talks and we even had a big
three-hour sit down where I laid out
certain rules but she's still ignoring
our wishes and doing things behind her
back with our daughters so at this point
it feels like distance is probably our
best option however my dad is 77 so
we're not sure how much time we have
left with him
um do you have any suggestions or
perspectives I'm missing I appreciate it
thanks
first of all these days 77 you're a
young man 77 is middle age these days so
I hope I hope you have time but you
never know you never know
yes some distance would be appropriate
probably if your mother is
doing things with your children that you
don't approve of and you're not
comfortable with and educating them in a
way that you're not comfortable with and
you actually have an obligation to to
make sure that you run interference
there and moderate that relationship but
distance doesn't mean you you never see
your parents or anything like that it
just might mean that you don't let your
mom take the kids alone to do whatever
they do that you're uncomfortable with
distance might mean that maybe the the
girls go out to lunch with Grandpa
instead of with Grandma on Saturday
afternoon distance might mean that you
go over and say hey to everybody for an
hour instead of spending
three days with them
distance doesn't have to be this
dramatic kind of blow up sort of thing
you just have to be
you just have to be prudent you just
have to exercise your judgment and and
get the message across to your mother in
a loving way you owe your mother love
and respect
and that said if your mother is behaving
in a way that is irrational you have an
obligation to protect your children and
your family from the consequences of
that irrational and destructive Behavior
so you've it's sort of like if you're
going to punish a child
when you lay out the punishment for your
child you should not be angry while you
do it you should do it in a way that is
level-headed and so that you are
punishing your child for the benefit of
that child and for the purpose of
Justice not as a way of venting your
emotions or getting back or or feeling
good or something like that same thing
with your mother don't you don't need to
blow up with your mother on the phone
and start yelling and screaming you just
have to say look I mom here's this is
right and here's wrong and I know you're
going through something right now but
but I've got to be responsible here and
just make sure you can't do that to my
kid and you can't lie to me about I
don't I I again I don't know exactly
what the circumstances but can't lie to
me about where you're taking the
children or what you're teaching them or
whatever so we're going to just have to
put some more safeguards in place here
so that you don't do that Mom nothing
against you but we have a responsibility
to our family okay next question
hey Michael you recently were talking
with Tim Poole about transgenderism and
Tim Poole brought up the idea of what if
we just create new sports leagues just
for transgenders and other such
proposals with bathrooms and things like
that so that we can get around them
invading women's spaces I think this is
a really bad idea I think it's a
dangerous half measure
for one very simple reason I'd like to
get your thoughts transgenderism just
like any other leftist movement is all
about transgressing traditional norms
and if they don't have those traditional
Norms to transgress they will claim to
be oppressed
the whole point is to live under
traditional society live with
traditional Society without having to
abide by its rules so what they do is
they corrupt traditional Norms they
retain their appearance in their shell
and they get rid of their substance and
imperatives
that is all of leftism so they will
claim to be oppressed if they don't have
these spaces traditional spaces to
invade I would love to hear your
thoughts on this thank you a really
great point and even more basically the
reason that well let's just add three
more bathrooms or let's just build 10
more sports leagues is a bad idea is
because it buys into the leftist the
liberal uh
desire to transcend all limits
conservatives recognize that Society
human life
everything in this finite World
necessarily has limits and is defined by
its limits and the Liberals include the
progressive liberals and the classical
liberals and all the kinds of liberals
want to liberate themselves from all of
those limits
but when we liberate ourselves from all
of our limits we destroy ourselves we're
left with nothing when you liberate
yourself from the limits of your own
body in biology you kill yourself either
in the figurative way the ritual way of
the transgender transition which leaves
leaves one's identity as a dead name
that's literally how they refer to it
or literally in the the the kind of uh
Robin Williams suicide the Oscars tweets
out Genie you're free this idea that if
you kill yourself you're somehow
liberating yourself from the constraints
of
the physical world you see this in a lot
of the arguments over euthanasia right
now
and met quote unquote euthanasia
medically assisted dying uh so that
that's wrong the idea that well the
problem is just we have too many limits
on bathrooms let's just add a new one
and a new one and a new one no
men and women are different the
difference between men and women design
Society Define society that limit
defines Society just as our national
border defines the limit of our nation
and so we're going to
recognize that limit we're going to
celebrate that limit that's what makes
us us just as the meter in the rhyme
scheme makes the sonnet the sonnet
without which it becomes slam poetry
which is the death of art the limits are
good embrace them embrace the No No is a
very liberating word
now we've got a lot to get to Mr Davies
tells me I come into the office today
I am I haven't slept all week I've been
traveling all over the country I'm
I'm I'm bleary-eyed okay and Mr Davey
says Michael
because I Ben Davies have screwed up
member blocks so much this week by not
giving you your beloved iPad we're gonna
fit in like three member blocks in one
today I'm very excited for that the rest
of the show continues now you don't want
to miss it become a member at
dailywire.com Knowles use code Knowles
at checkout for two months free on all
annual plans
[Music]
foreign